Growing up,
I thought that if I just lost weight then people would wanna date me.
Like, I thought that like,
that was the one thing that was keeping me from like
being relationship dating, whatever. Um,
cause I. I grew up especially like a very like fat phobic area,
but whatever. Um.
Turns out the issue now
growing up is not the people are attracted to me.
Finding someone to be attracted to
is not the most difficult part about dating.
The most difficult part about dating is like how boring people are.
It's like finding people that you find interesting
and you like their personality and they like yours.
Like, the amount of people that I scared off,
not with my size, but with my personality,
cause I'm like a little intense and amongst other things,
but also like, I don't find a lot of people like,
interesting enough to talk to.
Like, if you're not funny,
if you're not intelligent,
if you're not kind, then like,
it's not gonna work.
And I didn't realize how important those factors were, um.